un soulagement du côté des clients et
des commerçants pour ce second
confinement les marchés sont reconnus
comme essentiel et ce dimanche malgré la
pluie et le vent
les clients sont restés fidèles c'était
vraiment dur au premier confinement que
tout soit fermé surtout qu'il n'ya pas
beaucoup de grandes surfaces avec des
produits frais sympa autre que le marché
ait vu qu'on est vraiment à deux pas
c'est un peu la petite sortie du
week-end cas c'est sympa je suis assez
favorable pour au moins ce marché de
produits frais fissot ouvrir puisse être
activé
d'abord pour le client qui est
nécessaire de pouvoir d'avoir des
produits frais il faut quand même pas
aussi aussi aux commerçants
le marché s'est quand même ouvert je
crois que chacun fait attention c'est ça
me semblait plus logique de le laisser
ouvert en avril dernier
seuls les halles avait pu rouvrir grâce
à une dérogation obtenue par la ville
pour ce deuxième confinement les étals
ont été adaptés les stands sont bâchées
faire la demande de la mairie de
versailles
on demande aux gens de ne pas toucher
mais bon moi ma clientèle délinquants
qui sont éduqués donc une pige pas
aujourd'hui tout le monde est équipé de
masques nous avons dû gel
hydroalcoolique à disposition pour
l'ensemble de nos deux de nos clients et
pour nous mêmes
après chacune de transactions nous nous
loue désinfecter les mains
la plupart du temps on prend on manipule
également l'ensemble de nos produits
avec des gants pour éviter cette
transmission
sauf nouvelle décision gouvernementale
les marchés devraient rester ouverts
pendant toute la durée du confinement
la ville de versailles n'en compte pas
moins de cinq pour l'alimentaire